Lisa hey Martha disintegrative tapas or
[Music]
I love that they present this naive
t-cell as if it's scared that's now what
naive means it means that it was made
within the bone marrow and it's ready to
protect us through our immune system
this is our immune system these t-cells
right here I'm gonna go ahead and guess
that these are infections chasing him
I'm not quite sure which these are they
look viral bullet si hoy de la moto a
totally Banzai bizarre Dada Carlson is
just not Taurus you know all right so
the influenza virus that's our typical
flu that we see each season now a lot of
people like to say that that flu is not
a big deal it's a huge deal there's over
half a million flu deaths worldwide
something along the lines of anywhere
from 30 to 50,000 deaths here in the
United States each season millions of
people affected and the way that it
affects you is really something cool I
hope they show it in the show it's gonna
be about the literally the flu virus
jumping in hijacking your own cellular
machinery to help it replicate within
your body and infect you that's why it's
like a zombie apocalypse going on right
now
[Music]
Costard Adam even Enzo kyokotsu Vedas
Emmett Athena Darcy Nathaniel chica
Boone reset it sons you to do is you're
nuts and it's it's it's Canada no sir
that is true that headaches fevers
muscle aches are the most common
symptoms now the influenza virus does
affect both the upper and lower
respiratory tract so you can develop a
very serious cough as well as a sore
throat serious nasal congestion
the most common way my patients describe
it is usually
like they've been hit by a train because
the fatigue and body aches and fevers
are so uncomfortable that's really the
hallmark symptom that you get with a flu
what happens when the virus actually
enters your body it enters through a
lock-and-key mechanism enters the cell
nucleus which is sort of the brain of
the cell and starts hijacking the cells
own machinery to copy itself in and
infect the rest of the body
now your body's defense system like this
neutrophil and the t-cell here as well
as B cells and macrophages they all jump
in in defense of your body to try and
eliminate this virus but here's where it
gets tricky your own cells are infected
with this flu virus so these macrophages
actually have to eat your own body cells
in order for you to get better and as
you can already tell where I'm going
with this if they have an overreaction
especially in severe influenza cases
that could be lethal in its own where
your own body's inflammatory process
that's meant to protect you actually
harms you
Oh Oh the macrophages here so the
macrophage I think macro it is like a
Greek term macro means big badge or
Faygo means to eat in Greek so it's a
literally a big eater where it eats up
the virus or in fact it cells by the
virus and there's actually two types of
macrophages one that causes destruction
and an inflammation which is good to
fight the virus then there's a second
type of macrophage that actually causes
tissue repair the macrophage itself when
it consumes a part of us infected cell
it's able to tell that other parts of
the immune system like the T cells and B
cells of what kind of virus is infecting
the body that's really important in cell
mediated immunity where your body can
actually create a memory so that if
you're infected with this virus again
your body knows how to combat when we're
talking about the different types that
influenza A B and C a is really the most
dangerous because it has the most
pandemic potential meaning that it could
spread and cause serious harm
in fact the major outbreaks like the
Spanish flu of 1918 swine flu avian flu
those were types of influenza A that
were devastating on populations with
this patient / imaginary body having
influenza B it's a little bit easier
[Music]
this is the most bullying I've ever
encountered in a workplace setting this
looks like a toxic environment to work
in this is really interesting that so
the infected cells remember are actually
hijacked by the influenza virus
therefore producing more infected cells
or infected particles of the virus that
then infect other cells what's really
interesting about the influenza virus is
that scientists have recently found out
that it's able to hide itself from our
own immune system and we're trying to
make strides and figuring out how it
does that not only for us to be able to
counter the influenza virus better but
also learn about how it is we can
protect ourselves from our own immune
system when it's over activated think
about those individuals who suffer from
autoimmune disorders where their own
immune system effects their intestines
their skin like Crohn's disease or
psoriasis if we can figure out how they
influenza virus hides from the our
immune system we can use that same
principle to shut down the autoimmune
issues that we can have
oh no it's infecting other cells
be friends I mean Sarah dying I'd ever
did you come on yeah you journey today
yeah come on corny it's also dated one
of the crazy parts about having
influenza is you may be infected with it
and spreading it up to 24 hours before
you even feel symptoms so think about it
I can be totally fine meaning not
showing any symptoms sneeze and be
passing the influenza virus to someone
right next to me really problematic
right [ __ ] you ah music ah Thomas a
serious muster whoa
I think it's the Dragon Ball Z cushy
configure psychotic muster mortal
naivety fabled there we go be so cold
they say thank you you guys see go-daigo
you booked you it's good so just so you
understand the whole process of this
when pathogens enter the body they're
labeled as antigens and they're
recognized either by the T cells or B
cells and then the your body creates
antibodies to fight off these antigens
now you actually have memory B cells in
your body which remember past viruses
that you've been infected with and have
already an immune response ready for it
for example if you get to vaccinations
for the measles shot like you're
supposed to you have immunity for pretty
much the rest of your life like 98
percent immunity you get chickenpox once
in your life you have enough antibodies
for the rest of your life so the way
that this works is your body gets
infected your immune system recognizes
it it fights it off but also catalogs
the infection to know what to do if it
returns in the future cost it may you
know so an important part of your immune
system is actually raising the core body
temperature which is called a fever but
it's actually important for your body to
be able to fight off infections not only
does your immune system in certain cells
function better when the temperature is
higher but the virus has trouble
replicating when the temperature is
higher so it decreases its effectiveness
and spread also B cells release
cytokines which actually facilitate the
inflammatory process helping your body
rid itself of the virus but those
cytokines those inflammatory cells
actually increase your body's
temperature that's part of their roles
[Music]
[Applause]
the reason your body has a sneeze and
cough reflex is to rid itself of a lot
of these pathogens the way that actually
they enter your body is usually from
respiratory droplets being in the air or
if you touch some of them that have
landed on a solid surface and then
introduce them by rubbing your eyes nose
or mouth that's why we always say our
fingers are the dirtiest parts of our
bodies and we have to wash our hands now
you heard me say chest compressions
chest compressions chest compressions
but I think nowadays we should be saying
wash your hands wash your hands wash
your hands
[Applause]
[Music]
this is such a great picture of like the
war-torn city it's something that I
often times try and explain to my
patients that come in because they have
a lingering cough even once the
infection is cleared this happens all
the time it's called a post viral cough
or post viral tussled tuff syndrome
really what happens is you have a war
between an infection and your body's
immune system now your body's immune
system has won the war you're no longer
in fact that you're no longer contagious
but think about the battlefield and the
battlefield is your airway it's severely
inflamed just like what was visualized
right there in the city it takes time to
heal all of that what happens when your
Airways damage your body secretes mucus
you don't feel good it feels difficult
to fall asleep you cough even though you
don't have an active infection so it
takes time to calm the body's immune
system it takes time to heal that's why
it's no surprise if you've had a serious
flu infection that one to two weeks
later you're still feeling rundown your
body's healing
uh-huh because he didn't have help from
his naive Tisa or macrophage to tell him
how to fight this virus but the beat
sound too cool to walk Masako it's a new
virus in the pain forensic data enabled
oh hang on okay
Sakai tech Enid idea Co Co Co see
[Music]
so this requires the immune system
cascade to start all over again with the
neutrophils the macrophage the
presenting cells the memory cells
everything has to start from scratch you
can just reuse the same immune reaction
that you had to one virus for the other
one sometimes there's crossover but not
every single time this is why we still
recommend that if you have a flu during
a season but haven't gotten your flu
shot once you get better you can still
get the flu shot and get benefit from it
the biggest difference we see with the
influenza virus and other viruses that
are circulating right now I don't want
to say the name because I'm gonna get
demonetised just for saying it once but
for the flu we have an influenza vaccine
that not only prevents it in a certain
percentage of the time but also if you
are to get the vaccine and still get
sick you'll have a milder course but the
biggest thing is we have an antiviral
medication that is fda-approved to treat
and prevent the spread of the influenza
virus it's called a Sultana veer and we
use it quite regularly in my practice
actually if there's a nursing home where
you have an outbreak of the flu we can
proactively prophylactically treat
patients who are healthy to not get sick
now if there's another virus one that's
going around right now I still don't
want to say it we don't have those tools
it can be quite lethal so we want to act
smart and it's the way we do that is we
wash our hands to limit the spread we
don't touch our face to limit the spread
if we're sick we stay home if we see
someone sick we try and stay far away
from them and most importantly we stay
alert not anxious I put together a
playlist for you guys of some
informative videos about some viruses
that are circulating right here hope you
enjoy them while staying happy and
healthy
[Music]